[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's Ukraine
this morning is claiming to have made
advances in the fierce months-long
battle for the eastern city of bakmu the
leader of the Russian mercenary group
Wagner also said the Ukrainian military
had made gains as that fighting
continues Our Charlie dag it was granted
rare access to another Ukrainian Town
only about three miles from Russian
positions where the few remaining
residents are living in fear of Russian
attacks he is now in Central Ukraine
Charlie good morning
good morning to you Vlad those attacks
have only intensified in recent days
ahead of a Ukrainian counter-offensive
president zielinski is urging patients
saying we'd lose a lot of people if we
launch it too soon
orecky Bears all the scars of a
Battleground Town sitting squarely on
the front line
above ground a ghost town of shattered
glass and destroyed buildings
but below we find Deputy Mayor Svetlana
mandridge keeping herself and her
community together how often does this
town get hit
every day she said every day we get
strikes grad missiles Rockets even
phosphorus bombs
she told us it's been getting much worse
and much bigger
she said only the strike so it's very
scary for people who don't have enough
time to seek cover
she takes us to a school that's been
turned into part bomb shelter part
Community Center
the last children left this town three
weeks ago it became too dangerous
from a population of around 14
000 there are now roughly 1400 people
left we're told this town comes under
attack day and night including targeting
this very School
[Music]
it's government calls shelters like this
a point of invincibility and that
defiant title is absolutely intentional
it's manned by volunteers all residents
here serving those who decided to stay
despite the risks what happens when you
hear the explosions
of course every time there's an
explosion very scared to hear that our
people may have died
as if On Cue she calmly explains that
was ours outgoing
there are hundreds of places like this
where residents facing anything from
power outages to daily bombardment can
meet to get warm get fed grab a hot
shower get their laundry done even get a
haircut from a hairdresser who comes
once a week this is like a little
village inside a village
you know it's
it's a village
civilization within all the devastation
Valentina petrivna told us her house no
longer exists after being bombed but
she's not leaving her hometown aren't
you worried about your safety being so
close
I'm not so worried she said I'm more
worried about my children my son is
fighting and my grandchildren are in
zapparesia they share more than a hot
drink and each other's company they're
United in defiance and hope that the war
will end soon and families will once
again be reunited
now even though that town is directly on
the firing line residents there tell us
they can't wait for that
counter-offensive to begin to push
Russians back far enough so they're no
longer interested in randomly bombing
their neighborhoods Vlad
small piece of civilization amidst that
Devastation Charlie dagada in Ukraine
for us thank you Charlie